let's say president trump says something
and it bothers
me or it bothers you or bothers anyone
you can then
insert my next statement he's not
talking to you
okay so if he says something that
bothers you
bugs you rubs you the wrong way rest
assured
he's not talking to you that insanely
powerful
to go at all times if you don't like
what i'm saying
then i'm not talking to you
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media
this podcast is for you well hello
podcast listeners i wanted to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by
grow with video live this is our
three-day annual conference
that this year is coming right to your
living room we have tickets on sale for
as little as
97 to attend this three-day virtual
experience with some amazing
speakers it'll be jam-packed of strategy
of community and networking and so
much more you can get all the details at
growwithvideolive.com
and today's episode i'm fired up for
because
sean is interviewing manny orango he's a
world-class communicator
and i am so excited because
communication is so
key when it comes to creating youtube
videos and getting your message
out there and in today's episode manny
really breaks down what are the mistakes
that communicators are making right now
and
what are the tips that you can actually
apply to your next
youtube video or live stream that'll
help you dominate in communication
lean in because right now we're heading
into today's episode
well hey welcome back to the think
marketing podcast i'm so
fired up because today i'm here with a
friend of mine manny orango
uh he's going to be helping us level up
as communicators look there's never been
a more important time to be a powerful
communicator storyteller
on social media in videos to build your
business and make a great impact and the
thing is
manny if you're just meeting him right
now is one of the most in-demand
speakers in america and around
the world he has a dynamic passionate
hilarious communication style
that allows him to make a profound
impact when speaking on
at colleges camps churches he's the
co-founder of
arma courses online seminary level bible
content and theology courses he has two
youtube channels
manny orango and a lifestyle channel
with his wife tia
called the orangos that's documenting
their journey through marriage
infertility miscarriage and faith
and he's also created speak easy an
online course
designed for communicators packed with
valuable information and practical tools
that will impact the lives of every
audience that
hears you and he's going to be breaking
down some of his most powerful tips
in this session today manny how's it
going man thanks for coming on the
podcast
dude first of all i'm stealing that bio
all right
because that is that is epic dude thank
you for having me on the podcast thank
you
for sharing your platform with me uh man
i'm doing
amazing i'm doing amazing it is sunny in
north carolina and uh super super
excited to get into uh
to help everybody who's listening
watching to to become a better
communicator because everyone has
something to say
and uh we've got to start to package it
a little bit better so that people
want to hear what we have to say so i'm
super excited yeah i love that man and
so let's just dive right into it but for
those that are just getting
to meet you what is your background and
journey
i mean just so people know about kind of
our relationship we actually spoke at a
youth conference
um i was there just talking a little bit
about kind of like youtube secrets and
talking to church communicators
um and that's when we first met and then
you came to our
church in las vegas spoke i think that
was the first time i heard you like in
entirety and was just like wow i am a
connoisseur as i'm sure you are as well
growing up in the church
of some of the great communicators and
the church world i believe has some of
the best communicators but even
absolutely but even um in personal
development
going to different seminars going to
different entrepreneur and leadership
conferences
there's some amazing communicators in
that space as well
and with no flattery intended you
are just at the top of your game when it
comes to clarity
when it comes to passion when it comes
to content
when it comes to all of the most
important things
of communication making a connection
with the audience delivery
the details in tonality i mean really
massive respect and it's also been cool
to see just your value system who you
are as a person
so what's been your background though
and journey to becoming a great
communicator for those listening of
course
this is the skill i mean it's not about
youtube it's not about instagram
it's about communication these are the
middlemen they're the vehicles
but but how did you you know kind of
walking
in your calling walking in your skill
set having
sharpened the saw what's the kind of the
background and journey to where you are
today and a little bit of your story
dude so i start i got an early start
which i think
is massive right you get a head start if
anyone's read you know
malcolm gladwell like you know you get
thousands of hours of practice by
starting early
i started practicing well i started
preaching i was 12 years old
and uh it's just because i had a youth
pastor who
took my desire to communicate really
really seriously
and um so man the first time like i told
him like i feel called to preach
i remember him saying like okay yeah
yeah like meet me at my house thursday
night like we'll go
like you'll preach and so dude i got my
best sneakers on i'm super excited
like i'm thinking he's gonna take me to
like a youth conference man we went to
juvenile
juvenile detention center and um and he
was like all right you're gonna
communicate
and so um and so i remember
like speaking like to this group of like
i mean 14 15 16 17 year olds
who were older than me but guys that
were in lock up right and so
maybe a couple of months go by and i do
the same thing like okay cool this has
been great
like i'm enjoying the thursday night
like lock up
like bible study vibe but like i want to
like adult
you know
[Music]
my house sunday morning and so again man
i'm like easter out man like i'm
i'm like thinking yeah my pastor is
gonna bring me to like a church it's
gonna be awesome
uh he brought me to a nursing home
facility and
like was like okay yep like here you go
and no lie like those lessons
like taught me like i may want to
communicate to this audience
but i'm never going to communicate to
this audience if i don't
like karate kid like wax on wax off
which i think taught me early on there's
always an audience there's
always someone who's down to listen to
you
hear you and you can't romanticize the
journey of becoming
like an incredible communicator and so
dude for years
i mean years i did nursing home ministry
like on like the first time of the month
dude until i was in college so like
from 13 14 15 16 17 so the
by the time i spoke to my youth group
for the first time
like by the time i like spoke in church
oh
man like the kid the the the kid like on
the front row who lives in a cul-de-sac
who had an attitude
was like not bothering me like you don't
phase me man like
i was just in lock-up you know at a
juvenile detention facility
like three weeks ago so i think that
um there are always audiences to
communicate to
and um i think that the journey to
become a great communicator
is like reaching into who
who are you i think a lot of times we
don't
have things powerful to say because we
really don't know who we are
i think finding your message is all
about finding who you are as a person
knowing what makes you angry know what
makes you upset so um i won't i won't
answer too many questions at a time i'll
stick to the first question you asked me
but
that's a little bit of my journey in
figuring out you know i i felt fully
alive when i was talking to people
fully alive when i was communicating to
people and so i stuck with it
and so how many years now have you been
really communicating seriously
so i got i got ordained at 20 years old
like
my church ordained me i started doing
middle school ministry
youth ministry probably around 1920
like and i'm 33 now so like yeah i mean
over a decade of um
like man this is what i do i am a
communicator
like i'm just gonna own it this is
exactly what i do but dude
from 12 to 17 is all of this
raw practice in and so that you're not
nervous i think part of the hurdle for
communicators is
not being nervous anymore like that
jittery anxious feeling
that impostor syndrome i just think i
got over that
sooner because i started sooner and
that's really the real advantage
is like confidence not even content but
just straight confidence
and so the confidence journey started at
12
13. the content the crafting
of the communicating started at like
1920
and um yeah it's been it's been a fun
journey
and then how many how many maybe like
units
whether that's sermons you know events
but now maybe youtube videos maybe
videos that have been inside of a a
course
webinars like i don't know you might
just have to estimate it but like how
many
at-bats do you think you've had now oh
man
oh dude it's gotta be thousands it's uh
it's thousands it's
yeah live audiences alone is in the
thousands
yeah yeah yeah live audiences alone
because so one of the reasons that my
pastor was adamant about me even
becoming a youth pastor
is because you know he was like look
you're gonna speak
52 times a year guaranteed guaranteed
you're going to get 52 at-bats
every single year and so again even for
youtube it's like if you commit
like that i'm going to put out one video
a week you're going to get 52
bats a year minimum so that's not adding
in
you know all the extra stuff that
happens and so
man in a year just one year you could
get 100 at bats
right and and so you've got to look at
every year that way like i can get 100
at bats this year
which man i would say like
i was really really good like speaking
to people that i knew
but then somewhere around 17 2017
i started getting invited to speak to
strangers which is a different ballgame
right like
it's one thing to win a home game it's
another thing to like win
away right with someone that you don't
know
immediately and i would say it probably
took me
i would say like 18 months
of like just like a learning curve of
like okay
here is what you do in the first five
minutes of talking to people who do not
know you
like here's how you win instant
credibility here is how
you know an urban black male can connect
with
suburban white females right like
this is how you know because i started
to realize
dude and i learned a lot of
communication just from pixar
like i think the greatest storytellers
of our generation is pixar right
and when you watch a pixar movie like
and i say this to everyone whether
you're watching a sermon
a comedian a pixar movie whatever you're
consuming
instead of eating that meal start to try
to pick up on the ingredients that are
in that meal
so when you watch pixar you realize man
like there are some specific things that
are just related to
animated film but they have a way of
making me
care about a character that i would not
have cared about
because there are central themes that
connect every human together
and so the goal is to figure out how
does a black urban
male from boston connect with
anyone because although we may be
different we're human and what are those
core human themes so
i had to realize early on if i'm
traveling to speak or if i'm putting
something on youtube
i have to figure out what are the human
things
that every single person cares about and
now i've got to talk about those things
right i'm not speaking just about the
things i'm passionate about
i'm talking about the things that i know
you have a need for or
you're concerned about and everyone may
not be battling through infertility
but everyone is battling through
uncertainty so how do i
not just talk about infertility but talk
about the uncertainty
and fear and so now i can take my
specific story
and i can relate to anyone because
instead of
being stuck on the specificities i've i
like hunkered down
on these wells that that
man connect every single human and so
again
different different at-bats like but
again youtube is a different you know
version speaking to people that you
don't know
speaking of people that you do know and
man whatever the learning curve is dude
at this point it's thousands man it's a
lot of bats it's a lot of head bats
well i love that you shared that and i'm
excited to get into some tactics and
practical things and in just a second i
want you to share
actually what we should do in the first
five minutes
to connect with people that don't really
know us yet
but the reason i wanted you to kind of
go detailed on your past
is it's probably not the most
encouraging truth about becoming a great
communicator
but it's the fact that one of the best
ways to level up is exactly what you
said do it a lot
put out a lot of bad videos before you
get to your good videos you know
a lot of times people see me too even on
video and they don't realize growing up
in the church
in youth ministry doing announcements
being told to speak sermons doing video
announcements for
church for years back in 2003 and 2004
were all of these moments where
i was terrible actually right but i was
putting in the repetitions
yeah and i heard a preacher one day say
that the best way to teach a preacher is
to preach a preacher
you got to do it you got to do it a lot
so for those listening
um do that live stream post those videos
and use your season in obscurity to
prepare you for popularity
um start a live show on facebook live or
instagram live where you go live once or
twice a week
and maybe no one's watching the point of
the show is not influenced yet
the point of the show is personal
development because that'll get you to
your greatness
but manny tell us i love that you
mentioned that you you had to learn
it's different when you're playing a
home game versus an away game
and so many of us want to build our
influence on video with live streaming
but we are getting in front of strangers
what have you learned about those first
five minutes
in doing a talk but it could be a video
or a live stream
of some things we could do to make a
connection with somebody that doesn't
know us yet
dude the funny thing right is that i
remember the first sunday that i
preached for my pastor
right every church loves their pastor
right like that's kind of like
i don't know top three reasons for why
you go to that church is
i enjoy the way this person communicates
so i remember the first sunday that i
preached for my pastor
and um dude
less than two minutes in people already
walking out right because
they're just like oh pastor annie's not
here yeah i'm out of here like
like this isn't what i signed up for you
know i didn't sign up for amateur night
like like i don't know this guy and so
it
it trained me to be like okay i've got
to come out
guns blazing like every time
because the first thing that people are
wondering is who are you
who are you why are you here and why did
my parents leave me with a babysitter
like just we don't know who you are and
so i started going
okay instead of walking up on stage and
giving like an introduction to who i
am or uh like even getting into the
content i'm like
i create three to four minute
like mini sermons and that is how i
start
so i literally take the stage and just
start communicating
and i mean like it can be whiplash
for people but it's like no no we're
going we're going straight in
and it's typically like an anecdote or a
story
or something that like immediately
connects people and because i'm
typically communicating in church
it's typically centered around the topic
of worship because that's
or worship and praise and singing
because that's typically what we
just finished doing so i get up on stage
and i immediately exhort and give
an admonition of giving light to what we
just did
then once everyone's like oh okay we're
in good hands
all right we feel safe with this guy
then i introduce myself
then i say where i'm from then i throw
up a picture of me and my wife
then i say hey today before you leave
i always love to make a promise i think
making a promise number one keeps the
speaker accountable
and it lets the person know this is what
i'm that like before i leave like
pastor manny said i'm gonna learn x or
i'm gonna
kill fear or i'm gonna get you know
confident whatever it is
so i looks like come on man before i buy
a meal i want a sample but i'm like
like case food restaurant at the mall
all right like i'm like
i've got samples like on toothpicks and
i'm giving them out
and that's the first thing i do on stage
the second thing i do is get people
acclimated with me
hey my name's manny you know this is my
you know throw up a picture of my wife
just because that creates relatability
and then i make a promise
i make a promise because everyone comes
into an event
with their agenda they they are hoping
that you
scratch their itch but that promise
helps everyone to know
no i'm not really here to scratch your
itch i'm here to scratch this
itch and actually the itch that i'm
talking about
is the most important thing and uh if
you as a communicator don't establish
what the most important thing is
people are going through life man so
they are they
are hoping you talk about the divorce
they're going through they're hoping
that you talk about
their loved one who may be in the
hospital or whatever
and you as a communicator have to
establish no actually
i'm gonna talk about faith because faith
will help you
with that loved one with that divorce
with whatever
these are the three things you want to
give people
a bite size and i mean bite size like
three minutes you don't want to eat up
all your time
two three four minutes of like
man if they saw a clip of you like on
instagram
that is what you would be saying
something that makes everyone go
oh wow we're in good hands number two
you want to then introduce yourself you
want to create human connection
throw up a picture of your kids or
picture your wife that actually really
does help
it's not just nice and then number three
you want to make a promise
you want to say hey today this is what
we're going to talk about
because it centers everyone and it makes
everyone
realize that what you're about to tell
them is more important than whatever
concerns they have so those are the
three things
and you want to do it every time in that
order
because if you mess up that order it
just i promise you
that's the right order i've done i've
done enough at bats to know that's the
right order
well that's so amazing too because one
of the things we've been teaching on
youtube
is lead with content and it's actually
called
my friend matt guelin calls it um the
kick
because at the beginning of a youtube
video you want to give a kick of
dopamine
that whatever the title promised they
get instantly so as soon as they click
on it
you're not like hey i'm sean and this is
what i've done you take it but you come
right in and actually
deliver content right away shockingly
fast
and i love the idea of coming out guns
blazing like zero to 100 real quick
deliver that value and then it circles
back like but hey we're gonna get into
the rest of the points but if we're just
meeting you maybe introduce yourself
builds that build that rapport kind of
show your values by introducing your
family
and when we think about like even
structuring webinars that's just such a
powerful truth of
of letting that person know that it's
not going to take us a while to ramp up
into this thing and i got
all this background of your story before
i really get
value first if you want to get that
youtube engagement
if you deliver that value right up front
and just like come at them so fast that
they got to watch the first 60 seconds
because they can barely
take a breath of getting value then
that'll even
translate to social media yeah 100
i love that i love that and i think
social media has helped us
right like twitter has helped us have to
say what we want to say in a
short amount of time right instagram
really
even though you can put an igtv on
instagram
people are going to watch that first
minute and so it's
helped i think it's helped everyone to
go how do i
how do i give people fire in 60 seconds
right and that is an indispensable skill
whether it's live recorded youtube you
want to give people
that first 60 seconds you want it to be
fire so
strong well manny let's talk about some
mistakes so
especially as it pertains to um you're
seeing a lot of stuff happening online
right now
you've we've all had our lives disrupted
with the pandemic and so you've been
doing more
online communicating plus you are a
content creator with a couple different
youtube channels
of course there's universal
communication mistakes and i'd love to
hear those
but from those that maybe you even turn
on one of their youtube videos or
something
what are what are a couple of the
biggest mistakes that people are making
that they could fix
to have more power and more impact when
they're communicating
number one i think that uh i think
that we are living in a time where
people
are like afraid to be controversial
which is like i i'm like no
that is controversial not controversial
for controversial sake
i say it this way that communication
should be provocative
it should always be provocative it
doesn't need to be controversial
but it should be provocative um and i
should know enough about my audience
to know what is going to provoke thought
what is going to provoke
response and what is going to provoke
loyalty to my brand
and so um i always say it this way you
know that
something is provocative um if it needs
to be proven
okay so the so if i get up in
in front of a let's say it's a church
and i say
hey everyone you know um jesus
jesus rose from the grave it's like
awesome like
everyone you're talking to already
believes this this is not a provocative
statement
right but um if i can actually then
couple that with
something that needs to be proven um and
that
that's really really powerful
provocative communication
um is is powerful because it's gonna
resonate with the people it needs to
resonate with
and it's not gonna resonate with the
people it doesn't need to resonate with
um
and so i think that sometimes we're so
vanilla
like bland that everyone's just kind of
like yeah i
like this sounds like everyone else
this sounds this blends in like
like this is cliche like this is not
authentic and i think being authentic is
resonating with
you you cannot resonate with a tribe
until you
figure out like what are my unique
values and my unique values are not
going to be liked by everyone
and that is all right a good great
communicators
have just as many haters as they have
people who love them like as
fans and so you've got to know what are
the
what are the core beliefs that i have
and who am i talking to i think sean
that's the number one thing that i've
learned
is like i someone said this to me when i
was young they said you know an average
communicator
asks you know how much time do i have to
talk
you know an average communicator asks
you know is it a formal event or an
informal event
a great communicator the only thing they
want to know is who am i talking to
because that dictates everything who am
i talking to
and what are their fears what are their
concerns what are their problems
a lot of times in the gospels sean it
says this that jesus
knowing what they were thinking said
right
jesus knowing what they were thinking
then
preached or then begin to teach and i
just think a lot of times we are trying
to
give people solutions without knowing
what their problems are
or without presenting a problem to them
first
and um good communication solves
problems
and and and sometimes the solution to
that problem
is gonna provoke thought is gonna be
provocative
and so that dude when i was younger i
usually just sit down with the bible
like ah
66 books i mean well i don't know what
to talk about you know
should i talk about ezra or john or i
don't know
but then you start counseling people and
you realize
from a pastoral perspective oh people
are anxious oh let's talk about that
oh people are depressed oh yeah let's
talk about that right so the patient
is the one that gives the doctor the the
is the one that drives what prescription
i'm gonna write
i think sometimes i'll click on a video
or i'll listen to someone talk
and i just go you're just writing
prescriptions you have no idea
what the patient needs you know who told
you they wanted to hear
this you know and i get it you
think that this is the most interesting
thing in the world but like
i you've gotta convince me that i have a
problem before you start telling me
about this thing that you're just
interested in so um i think if you can
turn your interests
into a solution then that means that you
can
speak to people's problems and always
have a voice
um so yeah yeah that that is like
number one do you know what people's
problems are and are you provocative
uh is is just basic
really really basic like anyone
listening anyone watching
you can implement that today you can do
simple research and figure out um
what do people what are people scared of
what are they concerned about
what is your audience that you're
talking to like
just yeah are they are they
are they 35 year olds who have small
children
like the more you can conceptualize that
audience
the more you can get you can start
walking in their shoes
and now like jesus you can you can say
jesus
knowing what they were thinking said and
it's like
we've got so much technology at our
disposal
we should know what our audience is
thinking if target knows what i
want you know like if every store
man i can't have a conversation without
them getting an instagram ad
that gives me five you know products
that they think can fix the problem
that they think i have so we have so
much at our disposal
i need to know what's happening in the
in the minds of my audience before
i ever talk to them um and that's just
the homework that i do as a communicator
that's powerful and that actually
reminds me of a video that you did that
i love
and you just shared one of the
principles um
of great communication that you learned
and noticed
from president donald trump the video of
course a little bit controversial a
polarizing figure for sure
but you mentioned you know provocative
communication has been
one of the things that this he's okay
with people disliking him he doesn't
have a fear of other people's opinions
clearly
but with what we saw with the election
results and what we saw with even
uh how we can mobilize people by
being provocative that's one of the
things what were the other powerful
communication traits that we can learn
love him or hate him that we can learn
from uh his
powerful communication that we could put
into our videos
our live streams and our content yeah
number one i think
the most powerful thing there's two
there's actually two
um the first one is most of the time
like let's say
let's say president trump says something
and it bothers
me or it bothers you or bothers anyone
you can then
insert my next statement he's not
talking to you
okay so if he says something that
bothers you
bugs you rubs you the wrong way rest
assured
he's not talking to you so president
trump is speaking to his base
all the time he's speaking to his tribe
and he's speaking their language
he's speaking their rhetoric um and so
that insanely powerful to go
at all times if you don't like what i'm
saying
then i'm not talking to you like and for
that to just be
that alone requires confidence
but again it requires me to know what's
happening
in the lives and the minds of the people
who do like what i'm saying who do
who my content resonates with them i
don't need to waste a lot of time
fighting with people who don't agree
with me i just
look at people who's my voice resonates
so that's number one number two
president trump
is amazing at connecting with people
who he has nothing in common with he's
phenomenal at this
he's incredible like let's think about
this this is a
wealthy individual who for the most part
non-wealthy individuals love the guy
and i like i'm i'm always flabbergasted
like
here we have a med someone who built
their brand
on luxury wealth affluence
and whose followers don't always even
look like
him and so i go got it again
like pixar there are core
human themes i don't have to
i can be opposite of you and still
connect with you
we can be in the same tribe because we
share
the same fears concerns core drivers
so the first thing is i need to know who
i'm talking to
at all times and i need to be aware
that if people do not like what i'm
saying i'm not talking to them
that's it like and it's okay
there are enough people who are into
whatever i'm talking about are following
that's
it i don't have to win over or waste
energy
trying to convince people who don't mean
like
it's a time second of all
just because someone isn't like me
doesn't mean they won't like me right
just because someone is
not like me doesn't share my background
or my upbringing does not mean that what
i have to say won't resonate with them
i have to figure out the difference
between the people who do not like me
and the people who just are not like me
that
rap different and sometimes they can
look alike i may assume
that because i am not like a person they
won't like me
but there could be people who have the
same come from the same neighborhood as
me
come from the same socio-economic
background as me are the same gender or
race as me
and they may not like me so i can assume
just because we are
alike that you will like me i have to go
no no i'm speaking to my tribe and the
people in my tribe are not the people
who are like me
they are the people who like and
resonate with the things that i have to
say
and that has happened at a value level
that happens at a messaging level
that has nothing to do with whether you
identify with
my gender or race or whatever my
brand has to communicate values it has
to communicate
something deeper than just the outward
trappings of what what would attract an
individual so i think donald trump
is phenomenal at those two things he
knows who he's talking to
and he's able to relate to who he's
talking to even though he may not have
things in common
he understands the common person
understands their fears
and talks to them brilliant
whether you like the man don't like the
man it's brilliant and every
communicator
should follow suit and learn and learn
how to do
those exact things man so many powerful
truths and i love
what you are describing there as well
that we really need to get in touch
with our values we need to get in touch
with what we stand for
we really need to be clear on our
message where it's coming from
and overcome the fear of being
misunderstood i think a lot of us with
social media
the allure is hey this is a global
audience i've got global reach
i can reach everybody i'm trying to talk
to everybody i'm trying to communicate
to everybody
but what you have illustrated here for
us is that
no not only is that impossible and not
only no matter who you are is everybody
gonna like you or dislike you or not
even care or pay attention
that when we are willing to speak
to our tribe when we're willing to speak
to our base or when we're willing before
we have a base
to speak to values and common
uh human common traits that we share as
humanity
just like pixar does we can start making
powerful connections and growing
our following starting to make a
movement and one by one
starting to impact people with our
communication manny
uh this stuff's been there are people
who don't like beyonce
all right so look if there are people
who don't like beyonce
you're not gonna convince everyone to
like you that's just not the goal
and i think that's a hindrance like a
desire to be liked
i think the image that we have of
someone on stage we assume that person
on stage is liked
but for everybody in the room clapping
there are protesters outside who don't
like
like whatever that person is saying and
so you got to be down with it all
it has to the the the clapping in the
room
doesn't affirm what i'm saying actually
the hate actually tells me that what i'm
saying is
probably striking a nerve and is
probably going to be remembered
um so we've got to get over our love
of being liked and affirmed that has to
come from within
my my acceptance of myself comes from
within it doesn't come from the people
who are clapping
and it doesn't come from the audience
and i have to bring that
um and i think we all can tell the
difference between
people who are living and dying by
popularity
and people who just bring their own
source of validation to the table
and um and rejection doesn't bother them
right
a youtube video getting 10 views doesn't
bother them
they just show up the next week and do
it again because
although they want this to be helpful
for people this is not a source of
validation
this is this is me just getting at bats
and
and i think that's the ice that's the
part of the iceberg
that um is invisible but it really
really matters
so powerful manny orango we have a bonus
session with manny
in our inner circle program for those in
the community that want to listen to
that
uh manny there's so much stuff that you
uh shared here we got to have you back
on because i know your your depth and
communication
um is is boundless right
we were talking though you said man i
could talk about this stuff literally
for days and
and it's true because you've got the
content you've got the experience
um mastery is in the details it's in the
distinctions and it's all these little
pieces so i know
uh you've added so much value to our
community today and thank you
uh for those that want to follow up with
you and connect with you what's the best
way to uh get in touch of course in the
show notes in the youtube description
we'll have
all of manny's stuff but what's your
what kind of projects are you working on
and what's the best place
for people to follow you and connect
with you dude the biggest two products
i'm working on right now
speakeasy and arma and you can find all
that info
just on my own instagram my instagram
handle is manny orango i respond to
every direct message and so uh a friend
of mine was making fun of me
like last week and was like yeah i was
gonna text you but i figured i would
just dm you
and so i respond to every dm i'm on
instagram
all the time so uh connect with me on
instagram it's the easiest way to
connect
and i'm uh at manny orango
on instagram so all anything that i'm
up to uh is the meal that i'm eating
the where i'm going where i'm hanging
out all that stuff is always on
instagram so
and shoot me a dm and i'd love to help
you on your journey to become
a communicator or or find the
theological truth with arma those are my
big two passions at the moment so
well i hope you enjoyed today's
interview with sean and manny and wow
i am ready to level up my communication
style as well
and one thing that i really took from
what manny said was way back in the
beginning when he said
you know don't despise the small
beginnings he started so young
and he started in groups where you
wouldn't most likely think that that's
where your first big breaks would happen
so
if you're in a space right now where
you're trying to level up your
communication
just remember that let's practice in
obscurity
before popularity did you know that over
on itunes you can subscribe
rate and review the podcast it means so
much to us here at think because it
allows us to see
what you think of this podcast but it
also lets apple know that they should
show it to more people and remember
you can listen to this podcast on any of
the audio spaces as well as on youtube
so make sure you subscribe there
too all right today's review actually
comes from podcast
critique they said i love this podcast
because it gets me more motivated to get
up every day and create i run a youtube
channel
inspired by think media i love you guys
so much
and same with this podcast god bless
well podcast critique thank you
so much for leaving that review and if
you've not left review yet
what what are you waiting for get over
to your apple itunes
leave that review and let us know what
other episodes you would like to see
here on the
in the future for the think marketing
podcast
well it's time to lean in it's time to
take action you've now got the
tips you've got the practical tips to
move your communication style forward so
let me ask you when's your next video
when can you take what you've learned
here
and apply it that's the action takers we
love here at think and remember
if you're part of inner circle you have
the part two
of manny's interview waiting for you
inside of your members area
and if you've not bought your ticket yet
to grow with video live
right now that is your next step head
over to growwithvideolive.com
claim your 97 ticket or our other two
ticket options
and we will see you at our annual
conference this year
i'll see you next time in the next
podcast bye
you